here's how you make a cozy cone motel
inspired bacon mac and cheese cone at
home
start by rolling card stock into a cone
shape and covering in aluminum foil and
coat with a nonstick cooking spray
next roll a package of pizza dough into
a large rectangle and cut into one inch
strips
starting at the point of the cone wrap
the strips around coat with egg wash and
bake in a 425 degree oven for 12 to 15
minutes
next the mac and cheese start by cooking
a pound of pasta according to the
directions
then cook your bacon and allow it to
cool now onto the cheese sauce
start by melting a fourth a cup of
butter in a saucepan over medium heat
and then add a fourth a cup of flour and
cook until golden and smooth
then add two cups of milk and whisk
until smooth and let the mixture thicken
over medium heat add half a cup of cream
cheese allowing to melt
then eight ounces of shredded cheddar
cheese and salt and pepper to taste
stir until smooth add in your cooked
noodles and mix to combine
fill your cones with the mac and cheese
top with the bacon
and enjoy let's make some iconic disney
snacks here are my top five disney
recipes you need to make at home
the cheeseburger pods from pandora are
always one of my favorites and if you
want a good hack for this recipe you
always can use flaky biscuits from a
tube for the buns
the tachos from woody's lunchbox are
always a fan favorite i mean who doesn't
love
chili over tater tots i mean potato
barrels if you've ever been to ohana you
know how good the bread pudding is
it's easier to make at home than you
would expect and you get to flambe which
sounds scary but i swear it's not
i'm telling you now if the spring roll
cart in magic kingdom is open you best
believe you can find me there
i'm making the pepperoni ones but i also
have the recipe for the cheeseburger
ones so take your pick on what you like
they come together really quick and you
also can make these in the airfryer
and finally my favorite snack slash meal
in all of disney world i have recipe
tested this one
so many times and i think i have come
close to perfection to making toronto
wrap at home so check it out
here's how you make the cheddar cheese
soup from lace ellie and epcot
this recipe is pretty simple we're
starting off by frying up some bacon and
into that we're adding celery and red
onion once that's cooked we're gonna add
in some flour for thickness
as always the full recipe will be posted
over on my instagram
then it's just a process we're adding
some chicken stock letting that simmer
i know that lace ellie is technically a
steakhouse but i think this is probably
the most famous dish on their menu once
that's simmered down and thick we're
adding some milk
the creaminess of the soup will really
come together in the last 15 minutes
simmer
you can't have cheddar cheese soup
without cheddar cheese we're adding in
eight ounces of shredded cheddar cheese
i prefer to shred my own
i just think it gives it a better
texture in the soup and then it's your
final spices which is tabasco
worcestershire salt and pepper
and it's canada so we're finishing it
off with a fourth a cup of beer
be sure to follow along for even more
disney parks recipes
do you recognize this snack let's head
over to magic kingdom and recreate one
of my all-time favorite sweet treats the
cheshire cat tail we're starting this
recipe on the stove with some milk and
vanilla and we're just heating that up
we're making an easy crumb hat the whole
recipe will be posted over on my
instagram if you have any questions
but then we're just taking eggs sugar
and corn starch giving that a mix and
then we're slowly adding the heated milk
mixture
back into the eggs just so we don't
scramble them it's called tempering
and that goes back on the stove until it
gets thick and bubbly then we're just
rolling out some frozen
puff pastry we're topping it with that
crumb pat and then we're also topping it
with mini chocolate chips
this is my favorite sweet treat in magic
kingdom it usually has its own stand but
right now you can find it at cosmic rays
then we're just folding it over
essentially like a book
and then we're just going to cut it in
one and a half inch section pop them on
a parchment lined baking sheet give them
a twist and bake them in a 400 degree
oven until golden brown
once cooled it's time to ice and that's
just powdered sugar milk and a bit of
food coloring use a spoon to drizzle and
you've got yourself a cheshire cat tale
from magic
kingdom